ça va bien comme ça bonjour a donc cédé
à tous je vais vous parler aujourd'hui
le thème de la conférence qui dure
quelques minutes c'est concerne
architecture le patrimoine et le
développement durable et le propos que
je vais tenir son issue d'une réflexion
tout à fait personnelle et donc rien de
ce que je pourrais faire ne pourrait
être que du constat - le thème en fait
quel est l'objectif de cette conférence
est de donner aux personnes qui
souhaitent faire des travaux de
restauration dans leur logement
une piste de réflexion ou du moins un
contexte dans lequel ces deux notions
dépassées moines et de développement
durable se sont se sont développées la
première la première notion donc celle
de patrimoine est une idée qui est née
en réalité de manière réglementaire au
19e siècle
elle est issue en fait des effets de la
révolution française qui ont entraîné un
tas de démolition d'oeuvre architectural
majeur dont vous voyez ici en exemple le
magnifique château richelieu construit
par richelieu pour lui-même qui en fait
le
modèle de ce que donnera à versailles
plus tard et qui a été l'un des
promoteurs xixème siècle entièrement
démonté manque les rangs du morceau par
morceau
ces événements là se sont répétées
évidemment dans toute la france et l
état français avait énormément de
patrimoine c'est la raison pour laquelle
au 19e siècle le premier système de
protection étaient mises en place par
l'état en protégeant ses éléments
d'architecturé comme des objets
cette idée a été concrétisée en 1913 par
la loi du 31 décembre qui a institué la
possibilité de protéger et aider notre
historique châteaux églises maisons de
particuliers
cette protection a été étendu trente ans
plus tard on peut voir l'image suivante
à ce qu'on appelle les espaces protégés
dans cet important cette idée est très
importante a été traitée révolutionnaire
et innovatrice en france mais dans toute
l'europe où chaque enjeu depuis donc
cette année un écart en tout chaque
monument historique génère un rayon 5
semblait de protection considérant qu'un
monument historique seul n'a pas 20 perd
de son intérêt si son environnement et
détruit une transformé sans tenir compte
de l'histoire et de l'esprit des lieux
donc ce rayon ce rayon de 500 m créer
une obligation à tout à chacun d'avoir
une autorisation pour tous les travaux
et les services de l'état ont la charge
de veiller à ce que ces travaux là ne
porte par d'un
à la valeur patrimoniale du monument
historique cet espace c'est comme
l'écrin du bijou qu'il faut protéger et
qui permet de les mettre en valeur
ensuite cette cette idée de protection
c'est s'est étendu encore dans l'espace
par la création de licite regard de la
loi de 1930 où la l'état français peut
protéger des paysages très grand
considérable pour des raisons
patrimoniales l'historique légendaires
ou artistiques en ce moment les gens
comprennent un site est en train d'être
protégé c'est un site qui a été décrit
par rabelais et c'est dans cette vallée
que la jument de gargantua à pisser
l'excusé moyen terme pour noyer et
pendant ces guerres picrocholines des
armées ennemies et c'est pour cette
raison que toute cette magie pas être
protégée auprès des sites
c'est assez intéressant cette notion de
protection ou encore encore évoluer
grâce à andré malraux ministre de la
culture 3010 l'action en 1962 cover
l'image suivante
or la création d'un secteur sauvegardé
un secteur sauvegardé c'est un élément
juridique et réglementaire
un outil qui permet de protéger
entièrement une city si vous avez donc
la ville de tours qui a représenté avec
son premier le périmètre acquis là des
années 70 le deuxième métier été validée
en 2010 2014
cette idée absolument géniale de
protection des villes a été associée à
une idée de mise en valeur
donc il ne s'agit plus notablement de
protéger un monument pour sa part le
monial uniquement mais de lui associer
cette notion de mise en valeur et la
mise en valeur du patrimoine c'est la
capacité en conscience en conscience de
l'architecturé en conscience de
l'histoire de modifier un bâtiment à
caractère patrimonial dans le cas dans
son contexte évidemment dans la
continuité de son histoire
mais en l'adaptant aux usages et aux
nécessités actuelles moderne et
contemporaine 7 - la nécessité c'est là
qu'on raccroche sur le thème patrimoine
et développement durable la nécessité
actuelle que l'on connaît tous c'est
évidemment la vue de contrer le rythme
climatique et l effet de serre dans
l'architecturé très important il ya
énormément déperditions d'énergie qui
est dû au mauvais mauvais ou système
constructif ou à de mauvaises de
restauration dans dans le patrimoine et
cette prise de conscience de la
déperdition énergétique des bâtiments
des logements et n'est véritablement
dans les années 80 suite à
l'industrialisation architecture qui est
des magazines et 60 qui a créé tout ce
que vous prenez c'est partout c'est à
dire les appelle les palmes ans lors
d'un ce et la consommation de terres
agricoles par la construction de
lotissements ou d'immeubles de par2
collective qui ont été construits avec
des matériaux modernes industrialisés
mais très peu performant en matière
en matière d'économie d'énergie on peut
construction en béton ou en parfums qui
sont des matériaux homogène et qui ne
permettent pas à eux mêmes dans leur
structure
le gros oeuvre de d'assurer en lui-même
cette cette performance fort de ce
constat dans les années 80 les premières
si des économies d'énergie nos mecs y
apparaissent pour se développer dans les
années 90 et devenir réglementaire en
2012 par la loi que vous connaissez tous
arrêtés 2012 sur le passé à l'image
suivante le pâtis patrimoniale anciens
on appelle un petit passé manial c'est
les constructions que l'on retrouve dans
nos centres anciens qui datent pour la
plupart du 14e siècle pour les plus
anciens jusqu'au xviiie siècle et peut
même pendant la révolution industrielle
était 2e siècle architecture à continuer
à utiliser les techniques anciennes de
mise en oeuvre
alors c'est assez intéressant de
constater et on le voit à travers le
projet le projet ateba c'est un projet
qu'elle était pilotée par l'émission de
la culture qui s'appelle amélioration de
la terre vit dans des bâtiments anciens
ce projet a analysé toutes deux styles
architecturaux de bosses de faire de
systèmes constructifs depuis le 14e
siècle jusqu'à nos jours et a permis
finalement de constater que le bâtiment
patrimonial et performant
seulement ils ne fonctionnent pas de la
même manière que le bâti quentin d'après
d'après la deuxième guerre mondiale
c'est le petit schéma où mon fils il à
la manière sur la gauche dont réagit le
bâtiment ancien et sur la droite le
fonctionnement de la construction des
bleus pavillon le tableau final
trois éléments dans mon wagon sabres la
construction neuve
qu'est ce que finalement le
développement durable de la construction
ces trois paramètres
le premier c'est évidemment celui de
l'isolation du bâtiment limiter les
déperditions la deuxième
le deuxième paramètre c'est générer une
énergie propre
un par le biais de panneaux solaires une
petite éolienne géothermie l'idée c'est
vraiment technique et le troisième
élément qui est sans doute l'élément le
plus difficile aujourd'hui à mettre en
oeuvre d'un point de vue technique et
économique
c'est celui du recyclage des matériaux
et de leur bilan carbone
ce qu'on entend par bilan carbone c'est
à la fois le coût carbone la
construction ces matériaux et le carbone
de leur transport les menuiseries par
exemple en plastique importés de chine
un bilan carbone tata est catastrophique
même s'il est performant techniquement
le bâti ancien lui il réagit
parfaitement parfaitement différentes
c'est un bâtiment qui d'abord utilise
des matériaux locaux qui évite des
trajets des transports de matériaux
qu'ils utilisent des matériaux qu'ils
ont une propriété tout à fait
particulière qu'on appelle l'inertie
l'inertie d'un bâtiment construit en
pierre en 18ème siècle 7e siècle ou même
en terre et en bois
le aux 14e et 16e siècles sont des
matériaux qui ont la capacité
d'emmagasiner l'énergie solaire dans
leur structure leur structure
moléculaire et de la retransmettre à
l'intérieur du bâtiment
température descend la nuit par exemple
donc la structure même constructive de
ses bâtiments anciens ont une
performance énergétique extrêmement
intéressant razer d'inertie ils ont un
autre
notre intérêt d'un tribunal point de vue
technique c'est celui de la régulation
des atmosphères en plus nette mosphere
intérieur inouïe froide parce que les
créateurs de choses les maçonneries et
leurs différents systèmes en suisse qui
fort différente ou jeux vont permettre
de gérer ligne de réguler cette humilité
et cette opération et je puis que très
souvent et châteaux les bâtiments
anciens est là il fait frais vif et
frais étaient relativement bon hiver on
veut passer à la
à l'image vivante le bâti patrimoniale 6
j'espérais par exemple c'est assez
particulier qui ignorent complètement
l'architecturé contemporaine c'est celui
de la connaissance de son contexte et du
climat dans lequel deux bâtiments a et c
était content
par exemple là dans l'est de la france
un chalet la couverture du chalet
dispose de petits crochets que vous avez
sans doute vu du beau ski qui a pour
seul objectif de retenir la neige la
neige étant un isolant extrêmement
informant puisqu'on est à l'extérieur à
-10° la neige ne descend pas en dessous
de 0,5 de crédit et donc la couverture
est en contact avec l'extérieur plus
favorable que la température l'autre on
peut utiliser l'autre
notre image l'autre image art dans le
bâti ancien du phénomène de condensation
séparer cette régulation entre intérieur
humide l'intérieur et à l'extérieur plus
froids intérieur et mis des choses
3 on a tous observé évidemment ça
phénomène de condensation sur les vitres
et en particulier sur le simple vitrage
de double vitrage ne permettant pas
d'assurer cette condensation
donc on peut on peut faire de jolis
dessins ou des projets architecture ou
encore fort intéressant quand vous
pouvez le constater mais surtout cette
humidité de l'air se condense sur la
paroi froide décembre les petites
rigoles vous avez plus observé de
l'appui des merveilleux en boire et
permet de gérer l'humidité intérieure
dans un bâti ancien quand on lit mais
est double vitrage on prend le risque de
la voir cette même conversation qui se
fait plus sur le carreau met donc sur
les murs et des effets de pourrissement
de champignons de le passer
l'architecturé contemporaine vous voyez
ici un futur projet de ville c'est un
peu près d'ath ans que nous inviterons
tous dans quelques années
c'est le principe de la bouteille
thermos l' architecture contemporaine
elle ne cherche pas à réguler son
architecture par rapport à l'extérieur
elle cherche à s'isoler complètement à
éviter tous les transferts de flux entre
l'extérieur et l'intérieur
évidemment d'après lui énergétique c'est
extrêmement performant on arrive même
des architectures à des maisons
positives qu'elles produisent plus
d'énergie qu'elle n'en consomme en
revanche on peut malgré évidemment
chacun que je voyais à sa couleur de sa
maison avec l'outil d'enfin s'ils le
souhaitent
ça c'est très contemporaine entre eux
mais on a encore un défaut il ya des
expériences sur sept sites d'injection
là puisque il est nécessaire de
régénérer l'air intérieur de manière ce
qu on ne respire pas un air trop
carbonatées et comme disait un et
professeurs jeu mais bien les théorèmes
tout corps à 100 dans un tuyau l'anc
race ça veut dire que vivre dans une
bouteille thermos ça veut dire avoir
tout un système de tuyauterie qu'on
appelle le double flux lé qu'il faut
entretenir tous les trois ou six mois
sinon nos pages et caricatures un petit
peu évidemment mais il ya quand même une
problématique hygiénique
derrière ce type de jeu passée la
dernière pour conclure ce propos on a
bien souvent des projets ou les
personnes souhaitant des économies
d'énergie les habits dans un bâtiment
ancien et xviiie siècles
ils souhaitent les consoles trop sans
doute est la solution qui leur vient dé
spontanément alors que ce bâtiment n'a
jamais été entretenu ainsi deux parce
que souvent
travaux des travaux à réaliser
véritablement direct de là et ils
veulent mettre des fenêtres double
vitrage en empathie anciens pour faire
des économies d'énergie parce qu'on leur
sens revient dans ce bâtiment que les
torts étaient une passoire où la chaleur
donc par park et comble par les cris de
sa dispositif non contrôlée ça on
revient à boucher un trou de la passoire
et considérer que l'ensemble permet de
15 d'économies d'énergie en réalité
évidemment c'est pas qu'un lorsque l'on
veut faire des travaux chez soi pour
assurer la des économies d'énergie pour
assurer un bon fonctionnement de la
carmi de son bâtiment qu'il est
nécessaire de bien connaître de
connaître son fonctionnement est de
commencer par les endroits où évidemment
la déperdition est majeure et ce qui
permet de placer son investissement de
la rabroue ya véritablement utile
enfin la difficulté que rencontrent
aujourd'hui dans la restauration du
patrimoine
lorsque au restaurent dans ses
dispositions d'origine un bâtiment pour
des tests demandés ternie on a une
difficulté liée au système constructif
aux entreprises au développement
économique de notre société qui ne
cherchent pas forcément à investir dans
l'artisanat dans le savoir faire local
qui est plutôt le coincer par des
réglementations européennes
c'est complexe et pas forcément adaptée
aux enjeux
j'ai patricot l'idée serait plutôt de
développer ses compétences et ses
connaissances là pour restaurer les
bâtiments de leur disposition d'origine
de façon hyper et c'est d'après
évidemment nécessité de berne
mais dans la connaissance la conscience
de leur architecture est ce qui
permettrait je pense de développement
local sans doute non délocalisables et
on parviendrait peut-être à passer du
développement durable théorique
européens 1 à une économie durable local
en matière d'architecturé vous remercie
de votre attention